[Music]
have you been here before if this house
was a crime scene and you were a suspect
you'd say no but what if scientists
could look inside your brain and work
out that you've been to this house after
all don't worry they can't yet but this
is one possible future use of a
technique called brain decoding we'll be
coming back to these rooms later neuro
scientists often use brain scanning
techniques like functional magnetic
resonance imaging to see which areas of
the brain are active during tasks brain
decoding looks inside these active areas
to identify more subtle patterns related
to particular images or ideas a typical
study would put someone in a scanner and
show them a series of pictures for each
picture the scanner records activity in
the areas of the brain responsible for
vision a computer program the decoder is
then trained to associate each picture
with its pattern to test the decoder a
new picture is presented the scanner
records the activity again the decoder
then compares the new pattern to the
pattern it knows from training to figure
out what type of object the person was
looking at
some groups have
further Jack Gallants lab at the
University of California at Berkeley
measured brain activity as their
subjects watched hours of movie footage
they taught a computer program to
associate the clips with brain activity
patterns as before then the decoder
reconstructed what the subject had seen
based on the brain activity alone the
computer sifted through lots of video
clips and produced an average here on
the right a best-guess that it thought
was most similar to what the subject had
seen
[Music]
decoding what people see is one thing
but how about their thoughts or even
their dreams here's a representation of
someone's dream decoded from his or her
brain activity
it's from yukia sukima Toni's lab in
Kyoto Japan his team got people to fall
asleep in a brain scanner and then woke
them up periodically and asked them what
they were dreaming about they noted down
the most popular categories of object
appearing in the dreams they showed the
same participants pictures of these
objects when they were awake and scanned
their brains again then they could tell
what was appearing in the dreams
producing depictions like this which
make about as much sense as dreams
usually do
[Music]
now back to those pretend crime scenes
could brain decoding one day be used to
extract secret thoughts or detect lies
John Dylan Haynes and his team based in
Germany had participants walk around
several of these virtual reality rooms
nicely decorated aren't they been in the
scanner they showed people more rooms
ones they'd walked around before and new
ones using decoding methods they were
able to tell with about 80 percent
accuracy whether a participant had seen
the room before of course this kit isn't
ready for the courtroom just yet
what if they'd been in the house but the
day before or after the crime
what if they learned to disguise the
fact that they're lying all challenges
that decoders will need to consider and
anyway says Haines as a cheaper and
quicker way right now to find out what
someone is thinking just ask them
[Music]